ARCHULETA. ATKINS BATES BAKER
OR JUST BRADFORD CABALLERO
PORTENDING DALLY DODD DORADO
EGGMAN GLAZER GONZALEZ GROVE
HERTZBERG HUESO HER TADO JONES
KAMLAGER LAYERED LEYVA MCGUIRE
MELENDEZ MEN NEWMAN NIELSEN BUT
CHAU A VOGUE. PAN PORTANTINO
ROTH RUBIO SKINNER AMBERG BY
CASKEY WIENER WILK. THANK YOU
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT
WITH THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE WE WILL BE
HELL WE WILL BE LED IN PRAYER
THIS AFTERNOON BY CENTER
PORTANTINO AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAINSTANDING AND WILL BE LED
IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG BY SENATOR PAM. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT. GRACIOUS AND
MERCIFUL GOD TODAY WE PRAY FOR
THE CONSOLATION. AND THE
COMPASSION OF THE ARMENIAN
PEOPLE AS THEY RECALL THE
GENOCIDE THAT WAS PERPETRATED
ON THEM IN NINETEEN FIFTEEN.
MAY THEY NOT DESPAIR AS WE HOPE
FOR RECONCILIATION WITH ALL
THOSE WHO OPPRESS OTHERS. THEY
ALL OF US THROUGHOUT THE WORLD
NOT TURN OR HEADS AN APATHY
WHEN INJUSTICE IN FOR IS
INFLICTED ON ANY OF OUR
BROTHERS AND SISTERS. MAY ALL
OF US LEARN TO PRACTICE
COMPASSION. BY TRULY. BY BEING
TRULY PRESENT TO EACH OTHER.
AND MAY WE NOT FORGET THAT
INJUSTICE ANYWHERE. IS A THREAT
TO JUSTICE EVERYWHERE. I VOX
BORDER NAY WE ASK THIS IN YOUR
NAME ON THEM. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
SALUTING OUR NATION'S FLAG I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH
IT STANDS. ONE STRONG. SENATORS
PORTANTINO AND CENTER PAN
MEMBERS TODAY WE HAVE SENATOR
LIMóN AND SENATOR STERN
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATORS. MEMBERS
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. FIRST WE'RE GOING TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
SENATE JOURNALS FOR THE WEEK OF
APRIL NINETEEN THROUGH TWENTY
SECOND TWENTY TWENTY ONE WILL
BE APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK. WITHOUT OBJECTION
THE FOLLOWING BILLS OF FOUR
MINUTES WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED ITEM NUMBER
FORTY NINE BILLS S. B. TWO
FIFTY EIGHT BILAYER. UNDER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. YEAH
SENATOR HERTZBERG FOR WHAT
PURPOSE YOUR RIGHTS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR PRESIDENT EMOTIONS
SOLUTIONS MEMBER THERE'S A
LETTER IN THE DESK REQUESTING
WITHDRAWAL OF S. B. SENATE BILL
SIXTY FIVE FROM THE HUMN
SERVICES COMMITTEE AND REFER TO
THE RULES COULD COMMITTEE ON
RULES I ASKED FOR. AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU CENTER HERTZBERG IS
ASKING FOR SB SIXTY FIVE TO BE
WITHDRAWN FROM HUMAN SERVICES
EVERY RE RE REFER TO RULES
CENTER BATES FOR WHAT PURPOSE
DO RISE. THANK YOU ON MR
PRESIDENT I RISE AS VICE CHAIR
OF RULES TO ASK THE REPUBLICAN
MEMBERS TO ABSTAIN ON THIS
ITEM. THANK YOU CENTER BASED
CENTER HERTZBERG IS ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTE. CENTER BATES IS
ASKING FOR AN EXTENSION.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES. BACKER I FOR JUST.
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO I CORTESE
AYE DALLY. DODD THE RAZA HI
EGGMAN. I GLAZER. GLAZER.
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG HI
WITH SO I HER TADO HI JONES.
KAMLAGER. LAYARD I LEYVA I
MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ. MAN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. A SHOW OF THE-
PAN I PORTANTINO I ROTH FIVE
RUBIO HI SKINNER I AM BERG I
WHAT COUNTS FREE ONE I WIENER
AYE WILK. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES FOR JUST.
DALLY DODD I GLAZER I GROWTH.
JONES KAMLAGER I MELENDEZ.
NIELSEN BUT CHAU VOGUE. WILK.
THANK YOU MA'AM SECRETARY THE
MOTION CARRIES WITH TWENTY NINE
AYE VOTES ZERO NO VOTES MOTION
CARRIES MOVING BACK TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS CENTER MELENDEZ
FOR WHAT PURPOSE DO YOU RIGHTS.
I MEAN THERE ARE NONE. THERE WE
GO- PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE
TWENTY EIGHT I MAKING A MOTION
TO WITHDRAW IS HEREBY FROM THE
SENATE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE RIGHT TO
THE SENATE FLOOR. WE MAY HAVE A
FULL AND VIGOROUS DEBATE ABOUT
THE CONTINUED MERITS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S STATE OF EMERGENCY
IT HAS BEEN FOUR HUNDRED DAYS-
IS DEEMED TO HAVE BEEN
TEMPORARY NOW LASTED OVER A
YEAR AND I ASK FOR YOUR I.
THANK YOU CENTER MELINDA'S
CENTER HERTZBERG. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR PRESIDENT FOR NO
VOTE ON THIS MOTION THANK YOU
SIR HERTZBERG CENTER MELENDEZ
IS ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE TO
WITHDRAW AS C. R. FIVE CENTER
HERTZBERG IS ASKING FOR A NO
VOTE SENATOR ARE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN YEAH NO ARCHULETA NO
ATKINS NO BATES I BAKER. NO
FORTUS. I BRADFORD. NO CUT BY A-
NO CORTES E. NO DALLY I DODD.
NO TORONTO. NO EGGMAN. NO
GLAZER. NO GONZALEZ NO GROWTH I
HERTZBERG. NO WAY SO. NO HER
TADO. YOU JONES I KAMLAGER NO
LAYERED NO LEYVA. NO MCGUIRE NO
MELENDEZ. I MILLION NO NEWMAN
NO NIELSEN I A SHOW OF BOTH. HI
PAM NO PORTANTINO NO ROTH. NO
RUBIO. RUBIO NO SKINNER NO
AMBERG NO WHITE HOUSE SKI. NO
WIENER NO WILK. I THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. HER TADO. THANK
YOU MA'AM SECTOR THE MOTION
FAILS TWENTY EIGHT NO VOTES
NINE AYE VOTES THE MOTION FAILS
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
THE CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FILE WE HAVE SOME SECOND
READING ITEMS SOME GOVERNOR
APPOINTEES AND SENATE THIRD
READING WITH SOME RESOLUTIONS
IF WE GET EVERYBODY'S ATTENTION-
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE
SECOND READING FILE. SENATE
BILL FOR SIXTY FIVE WITH
AMENDMENTS THREE FORTY WITH
AMENDMENTS FOR THIRTY SEVEN
WITH AMENDMENTS FIVE OH NINE
WITH AMENDMENTS FIVE THIRTY
FIVE WITH AMENDMENTS SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION THIRTY
SIX WITH AMENDMENTS AND SENATE
BILL FIVE THIRTY THREE WITH
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY MOVING ONTO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES SENATOR
BATESYOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN THE
CONFIRMATION OF ZERO ALSO INTO
THE COMMISSION ON STATE
MANDATES. PRIOR TO HER
RETIREMENT MISSILES AND WAS
STAFF DIRECTOR OF REPUBLICAN
FISCAL COMMITTEES IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY. SHE
HAS SERVED ON THE COMMISSION
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIVE AND WAS
APPROVED BY THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE ON APRIL FOURTEENTH.
ARE ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. MEMBER CENTER BASES-
SUGGESTING A GOVERNOR APPOINTEE
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION ON. THE
APPOINTEE MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION ON THE POINT
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEE. SAYING
NINE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS AYE BATES. I BAKER. FIVE
FORTUS HI BRADFORD FIVE
CABALLERO HIGH COURT TODAY FIVE
DALLY HI DODD. FIVE TORONTO HI
EGGMAN. I GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I
GROWTH AYE HERTZBERG. I HUESO.
FIVE HER TADO I JONES I
KAMLAGER I LAYERED I LEYVA FIVE
MCGUIRE. I MELENDEZ I MEN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN I WILL TELL
BOTH. HI PAN AYE PORTANTINO. HI
ROTH HI RUBIO I SKINNER. HI I'M
BURKE ALL RIGHT I BY CAL SKI
FIVE WIENER. I WILK HI THANK
YOU MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. THAT'S
RIGHT THAT FULL HOUSE IS THIRTY
EIGHT KNOWS KNOWS THE APPOINTEE
IS APPROVED. MEMBERS WE ARE
BEING REMINDED TO- PLEASE
SOCIALLY DISTANCE AND IF YOU
HAVE DISCUSSIONS TO PLEASE TAKE
THEM OFF THE FLOOR REMOVING ON
TWO RESOLUTIONS. BY THE
MEMBERS- SO WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE WOULD LIKE TO MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM SIXTY FOUR. AND WE
ARE RECOGNIZING- SENATOR RUBIO
ON ITEM SIXTY FOUR. SENATE
RUBIO YOU HAVE THE FLOOR.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE TODAY RIGHT I'M SORRY
CENTER RUBIO- THE NEW BE MADE A
MISTAKE I APOLOGIZE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
RESOLUTION TWENTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR RUBIO RELATIVE TO
SEXUAL ASSAULT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT AT FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT WHICH PROCLAIM APRIL
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS SEXUAL
ASSAULT AWARENESS MONTH. AND
DESIGNATES APRIL TWENTY EIGHTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE S. DENIM DAY
CELEBRATING ITS TWENTY TWO YEAR
ANNIVERSARY AND I WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUES FOR KILEY WEARING
JEANS ON THE FLOOR AND ARE ALSO
WORRIED MASS IN HONOR OF THE
STATE. THE NATIONAL INTIMATE
PARTNER AND SEXUAL VIOLENCE
LEVINE SERVICE REPORTS THAT
THERE ARE TWENTY TWO MILLION
SURVIVORS ARE FREE. TWO MILLION
OF THOSE SURVIVORS LIVING HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IT
IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
SUPPORT ALL RATE AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT VICTIMS AND RAISE
AWARENESS. AND EDUCATION ON
THIS ISSUE. BUT IS DENIM DAY
AND WHY IS IT CALLED DENIM DAY.
IN NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT THE%
TALIBAN SUPREME COURT
OVERTURNED THE CONVICTION OF A
MAN WHO SEXUALLY ASSAULTED AN
EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD WOMAN. ONLY
BECAUSE SHE WORE TIGHT JEANS I
WANT US TO THINK ABOUT THAT FOR
A SECOND. IT'S ANOTHER WAY OF
SAYING IT WAS HER FAULT. SHE
DESERVED IT. M. RATES BY THE
COURT'S DECISION WITHIN HOURS
WOMEN IN THE ITALIAN PARLIAMENT
LAUNCHED INTO IMMEDIATE ACTION
AND PROTESTED BY WEARING JEANS
TO WORK NATION'S AND STATES
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD HAVE
FOLLOWED THE LEAD OF THE
ITALIAN PARLIAMENT BY
DESIGNATING THEIR OWN DENIM DAY
TO RAISE PUBLIC AWARENESS ABOUT
RAPE AND SEXUAL ASSAULT. THIS
RESOLUTION ENCOURAGES ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO WEAR JEANS ON
DENIM DAY WHICH HELPS
COMMUNICATE A MESSAGE THAT
THERE IS NO EXCUSE FOR EVER AN
INVITATION TO COMMIT RAPE. RAPE
AND SEXUAL ASSAULT IMPACTS
PEOPLE OF ALL RACES. ALL
CULTURAL BACKGROUNDS AND
ECONOMIC BACKGROUNDS HARMFUL
ATTITUDES ABOUT RAPE AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT ALLOW THESE KINDS TO
PERSIST AND FOR SURVIVORS TO BE
RE VICTIMIZE THE VICTIM BLAMING
THE VICTIM SHAMING. DENIM DAY
IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL OF US
TO WEAR JEANS FOR A PURPOSE TO
SUPPORT SURVIVORS AND EDUCATE
ABOUT THE DIFFERENT FORMS OF
SEXUAL VIOLENCE BANKER TO SHARE
THE MEANING OF THE STATE WITH
YOUR FRIENDS FAMILIES.
GRANDKIDS NOT JUST TODAY FOUR
ON WEDNESDAY BUT EVERY DAY AND
CONTINUE TO KEEP THIS
CONVERSATION GOING SO THAT WE
CAN DO BETTER FIVE VICTIMS.
THANK YOU MEMBERS AND I
RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR AN IDOL.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO HERE
ANY TO. ON THE RESOLUTION.
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION. THIS
RESOLUTION QUALIFIES FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. NO OBJECTION THE MEMBER
THE JUST RESOLUTION PASSES
THIRTY EIGHT AYE VOTES ZERO NO
VOTES MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIXTY FIVE THAT'S OUR
TWENTY NINE SENATOR ARCH A
LETTER YOU PER READY PREPARED
TO PRESENT. SERDULA SURGERY
PLEASE READ. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS VERY PLEASE
READ. SENATE RESOLUTION TWENTY
NINE BY SENATOR ARCHULETA
RELATIVE TO THE COMMEMORATION
OF THE ANNIVERSARY OF THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE OF
1-950-152-1920 THREE CENTER
ARCHULETA YOU HAVE THE FLOOR
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
I WANTED TO LET YOU ALL KNOW
THAT OVER THE TABLE OUTSIDE THE
OFFICE THE SERGEANT'S OFFICE WE
HAVE AN ARMENIAN BOOK FOR YOU.
CALLED LOVE AUCH THE BREAD THAT
LAUNCHED A THOUSAND MEALS BY
AUTHORS KATE THE HE ARA ZADA
AND JOHN LEE IT HAS RECIPES AND
INSIGHT INTO THE ARMENIAN
CULTURE I ENCOURAGE THAT YOU
GRAB A COPY ON YOUR WAY OUT
COMPLIMENTS OF THE ARMENIAN
CAUCUS. AND MR PRESIDENT. I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT SENATE
BILL RESOLUTION TWENTY NINE
COMMEMORATING THE ANNIVERSARY
OF THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE. AS A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
ARMENIAN LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I
AM GRATEFUL AND PROUD. THAT FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN OUR NATION'S
HISTORY UNITED STATES HAS
FORMALLY RECOGNIZED THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE ON THIS IT'S
ONE HUNDRED SIX ANNIVERSARY.
WHAT WAS SANCTIONED BY THE
OTTOMAN EMPIRE AND BEGAN ON
APRIL TWENTY FOURTH NINETEEN
FIFTEEN WHAT'S THE FIRST STATE
SPONSORED GENOCIDE IN MODERN
TIMES. IT RESULTED IN THE DEATH
OF ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
VICTIMS MEN WOMEN AND CHILDREN
ALL HORRIBLY KILLED. ENTIRE
COMMUNITIES WERE FORCIBLY
MARCHED TO THEIR DEATHS WERE
MURDERED IN ATTEMPT TO GET RACE
THEIR PRESENCE FROM A REGION
THEY HAD PEACEFULLY RESIDED IN
FOR OVER FOUR THOUSAND YEARS.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO THE
LARGEST ARMENIAN AMERICAN
POPULATION IN THE UNITED STATES
BECAUSE OF THIS WE HAVE A
UNIQUE RESPONSIBILITY. TO
SAFEGUARD THIS IS STORE CO
RECOGNITION. WE MUST UPHOLD ITS
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE FUTURE
GENERATIONS LEARN OF ITS IN
HUMANITY. AND TO PREVENT ANY
ATROCITY IT LIKE THIS FROM EVER
HAPPENING AGAIN. I AM ETERNALLY
GRATEFUL FOR THE ARMENIAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY AND THE
DESCENDANTS OF SURVIVORS ACROSS
THE GLOBE FOR THEIR
PERSEVERANCE AND DEDICATION THE
C. THE RECOGNITION WITH
BROUGHT. TO THOSE WHOSE LIVES
WERE STOLEN. IN ORDER TO
PRESENT. IN ORDER FOR PRESENT
AND FUTURE GENERATIONS TO LEARN
ABOUT THE INJUSTICES THAT HAVE
BEFALLEN THEIR ANCESTORS THERE
MUST BE A COMPLETE AND ACCURATE
ACCOUNT OF THEIR HISTORY. ONLY
THEN CAN WE PREVENT THE ISSUES
OF TODAY FROM COMPOUNDING AND
DEVELOPING INTO THE INJUSTICES
OF TOMORROW FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SEEN OUR
CHILL EXCELLENT PRESENTATION
MEMBERS ANNE'S- DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE I'M SEEING A COUPLE OF
MICROPHONES GOING UP. CENTER
BOARD JUST WILL GO WITH YOU
FIRST AND THEN CENTER
PORTANTINO WHEN THEY WILL CARRY
ON FROM THERE CENTER GORGEOUS
MISTER PRESIDENT MAY I FIRST OF
HER TO THE CHAIR OF THE
ARMENIAN CAUCUS TO GO AHEAD OF
ME. THAT WOULD BE FINE THANK
YOU MISTER BURGESS MISTER
PORTANTINO. THANK YOU- MISTER
PRESIDENT- I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
SR TWENTY NINE. FORMALLY
REAFFIRMING CALIFORNIA'S
RECOGNITION OF THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE. AND DESIGNATED THE
MONTH OF APRIL FOURTH
COMMEMORATION. HUNDRED SIX
YEARS AGO ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION ARMENIANS AND HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF ASSYRIANS
GREEKS AND OTHER CHRISTIANS
WERE PERSECUTED AND KILLED AT
THE HANDS OF THE OTTOMAN TURKS.
THE ARMENIAN DIASPORA WAS
LARGELY FORMED A RESULT AS A
RESULT OF THE GENOCIDE TODAY
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO A LARGE
AND VIBRANT ARMENIAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY THAT CONTRIBUTES TO
OUR RICH CULTURAL DIVERSITY AND
WHO ARE THE DESCENDANTS OF THE
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION LOST
DURING THE GENOCIDE. SADLY LAST
YEAR HATE CRIMES AGAINST AREN'T
THE ARMENIAN COMMUNITY REPORTED
IN OUR GREAT STATE. THE KGV
ARMENIAN SCHOOL WAS VANDALIZED
AND SHOTS WERE FIRED AT THE
SCHOOLS BUILDING. SIMILAR
INCIDENTS INVOLVED RACIALLY
CHARGED ANTI ARMENIAN VANDALISM
TOOK PLACE IN LOS ANGELES THE
PREVIOUS YEAR FORCING THE
ARMENIAN FAMILIES TO BE ON HIGH
ALERT. FOR CALIFORNIANS AND
BECAUSE OF THOSE RECENT ACTS OF
HATE THE STATEMENT BY PRESIDENT
BIDEN ON SATURDAY RECOGNIZING
THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE IS
HISTORIC. IMPORTANT AND WELCOME.
PERMISSION TO READ THE
PRESIDENT'S STATEMENT
PERMISSION GRANTED THANK YOU
THANK YOU. FROM PRESIDENT BIDEN
EACH YEAR ON THIS DAY WE
REMEMBER THE LIVES OF ALL THOSE
WHO DIED IN THE OTTOMAN ERROR
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE AND RECOMMIT
OURSELVES TO PREVENTING SUCH AN
ATROCITY FROM EVER OCCURRING
AGAIN. BEGINNING ON APRIL
TWENTY FOURTH NINETEEN FIFTEEN
WITH THE ARREST OF ARMENIAN
INTELLECTUALS AND COMMUNITY
LEADERS IN CONSTANTINOPLE BY
THE OUR AUTOMATIC PARTIES ONE
AND A HALF MILLION ARMENIANS
WERE DEPORTED MASSACRED OR
MARCHED TO THEIR DEATHS IN A
CAMPAIGN OF EXTERMINATION. WE
HONOR THE VICTIMS OF MEDS YET
AND SO THAT THE HORRORS OF WHAT
HAPPENED ARE NEVER LOST TO
HISTORY. AND WE REMEMBER SO
THAT WE REMAIN EVER VIGILANT
AGAINST THE CORROSIVE INFLUENCE
OF HATE IN ALL OF ITS FORMS. OF
THOSE WHO MOST WERE
FORCED TO FIND NEW HOMES AND
NEW LIVES AROUND THE WORLD
INCLUDING IN THE UNITED STATES.
WITH STRENGTH AND RESILIENCE
THE ARMENIAN PEOPLE SURVIVED
AND REBUILT THEIR COMMUNITY.
OVER THE DECADES ARMENIAN
IMMIGRANTS SEVEN RICH THE
UNITED STATES IN COUNTLESS WAYS
BUT THEY HAVE NEVER FORGOTTEN
THE TRAGIC HISTORY THAT BROUGHT
SO MANY OF THEIR ANCESTORS TO
OUR SHORES. WE HONOR THEIR
STORY WE SEE THAT PAIN WE
AFFIRM THAT HISTORY WE DO THIS
NOT TO CAST BLAME BUT TO ENSURE
THAT WHAT HAPPENED IS NEVER
REPEATED. TODAY AS WE MOURN
WHAT WAS LOST LET US ALSO TURN
OUR EYES TO THE FUTURE FOR THE
WORLD THAT WE WISH TO BUILD FOR
OUR CHILDREN. THE WORLD UNST
UNSTAINED BY THE DAILY EVILS OF
BIGOTRY AND INTOLERANCE WERE
UMAN RIGHTS ARE RESPECTED AND
WHERE ALL PEOPLE ARE ARE ABLE
TO PURSUE THEIR LIVES IN
DIGNITY AND SECURITY. LET US
RENEW OUR SHARED RESOLVE TO
PRESENT TO PREVENT FUTURE
ATROCITIES FROM OCCURRING
ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD AND
THAT'S PURSUE HEALING AND
RECONCILIATION. FOR ALL THE
PEOPLE OF THE WORLD. AMERICAN
PEOPLE HONOR ALL THOSE
ARMENIANS WHO PERISHED IN THE
GENOCIDE THAT BEGAN A HUNDRED
AND SIX YEARS AGO TODAY.
PRESIDENT JOSEPH R. BIDEN. ONE
MIGHT ASK WHY THE EVENTS OF A
HUNDRED SIX YEARS AGO BEAR
MENTIONING. AND RETELLING TODAY.
BECAUSE WE MAY BE A CENTURY
REMOVED FROM THE GENOCIDE BUT
WE CONTINUE TO BE CONFRONTED
WITH THE EFFORTS PROVIDE TO
DRIVE ARMENIANS FROM THEIR
HOMELANDS. LAST SEPTEMBER
AZERBAIJAN WITH THE HELP OF
TURKEY LAUNCHED AN UNPROVOKED
ATTACK ON ARMENIANS IN ARTSAKH.
OVER A HUNDRED AND FIVE YEARS
AFTER THE GENOCIDE THE CHILDREN
AND GRANDCHILDREN OF GENOCIDE
SURVIVORS FACED ANOTHER
EXISTENTIAL TRACK CORRECT.
NEARLY FIVE THOUSAND ARMENIANS
WERE KILLED AND THOUSANDS OF
OTHERS DISPLACED FROM THEIR
HOMES AND THE LAND OF THEIR
ANCESTORS DURING THE SECOND
ARTSAKH WAR. ARMENIA HAS
FULFILLED ITS OBLIGATION OF THE
PEACE AGREEMENT BY THE
GOVERNMENT OF AZERBAIJAN
CONTINUES TO RIP MISREPRESENT
THE STATUS OF P. O. W.'S IN AN
ATTEMPT TO JUSTIFY CONTINUED
ACT CAPTIVITY. TO THIS DATE TWO
HUNDRED ARMENIAN DETAINEES
REMAIN IN AZERBAIJANI CUSTODY
AMONG THEM CIVILIANS. DURING MY
LAST TRIP TO ARTSAKH IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. I MET A
BRIDE AND GROOM ON THEIR
WEDDING DAY AT A BEAUTIFUL
NINETEENTH CENTURY CATHEDRAL IN
THE CITY OF SHUSHI. SHUSHI
TODAY IS UNDER AZERBAIJANI
CONTROL AND THE CATHEDRAL. HAS
BEEN DAMAGED. SIGNIFICANTLY IN
THE HOW THE REGION OF ARTSAKH
PEOPLE THAT I HAD LUNCH WITH
WERE WOUNDED AND ONE WAS KILLED.
THAT'S WHY. WE RECOGNIZE TODAY.
TURKEY AND AZERBAIJAN MUST BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
GENOCIDE AND THEIR CURRENT
AGGRESSION. ATROCITIES FROM
OVER A CENTURY AGO MUST BE
RECOGNIZE NOW TO HELP PREVENT
THE REOCCURRENCE IN THE FUTURE.
AND TO HELP A COMMUNITY TRY TO
HEAL. MANY ARMENIANS HAVE
EXHIBITED INSPIRED THEIR
COMPATRIOTS WITH THE PHRASE OF
REASSURANCE. HELLO COOPER DE
LEóN I'M AN INCH LOVE HEY WE
KNOW WHO. SENATORS IN HONOR OF
THE ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
ARMENIANS THAT PERISHED AND
EVERY CALIFORNIA FAMILY
AFFECTED BY THE ARTSAKH WAR I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU JOIN
ME IN APPROPRIATELY CASTING AN
AYE VOTE FOR SR TWENTY NINE.
THANK YOU AND GOD BLESS
OSTEOBLAST WATER NAY. SAN
PORTANTINO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONTINUED LEADERSHIP AND
PASSION ON THIS ISSUE. AND YOUR
WORDS IN SUPPORT OF SR TWENTY
NINE X. WILL GO TO SENATOR
GORGEOUS AND THEN DR PAM.
PRESIDENT. I TO RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SR TWENTY NINE.
APRIL TWENTY FOURTH AS WE CAN
AS WE'VE LEARNED COMMEMORATES
THE HUNDRED SIXTY OF THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE. NO DOUBT ONE
OF THE DARKEST CHAPTERS IN
WORLD HISTORY. AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF A SIGNIFICANT
ARMENIAN COMMUNITY WITH DEEP
TIES THROUGH FAMILY AND FAITH.
THIS ISSUE HITS VERY CLOSE TO
HOME. MY WIFE'S GRANDMOTHER WAS
A GENOCIDE SURVIVOR WHO FLED
FROM SMYRNA TO GREECE AND IT
FINALLY CAME TO CALIFORNIA IN
THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES.
CALIFORNIA'S CENTRAL VALLEY IS
HOME TO AN ESTIMATED HUNDRED
THOUSAND ARMENIAN AMERICANS
WITH FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
APPROXIMATELY RESIDING IN
FRESNO COUNTY. WHICH IS WHERE I
CALL HOME. I'VE TRAVELED MANY
TIMES TO ARMENIA AND ARTSAKH
AND I FEEL VERY CONNECTED TO
THE REGION IN FACT I WENT TO
YEREVAN TO- PICK UP A GIRL AND
BRING HER TO GREECE AND ASK HER
TO MARRY ME. SO WE SPENT A GOOD
AMOUNT OF TIME IN THE IN THIS
REGION BUT WE COME TOGETHER TO
HONOR. THE ONE AND A HALF
MILLION ARMENIANS. AND AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE. WELL WE REFER
TO THIS IS THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE. IT ALSO INCLUDED A
SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF ORTHODOX
CHRISTIAN MINORITIES
THROUGHOUT- THE OTTOMAN EMPIRE.
AT LEAST FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND-
ANATOLIAN GREEKS IN ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND PONTIC GREEKS
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
ASSYRIANS SO WELL OVER TWO
MILLION PEOPLE WERE KILLED. AT
THE HANDS OF THE ALDERMAN
APPARATUS. BUT THESE ATROCITIES
AS WE'VE HEARD FROM- THE CHAIR
OF THE ARMENIAN CAUCUS ARE JUST
LIMITED TO THE EVENTS THAT
OCCURRED BETWEEN. NINETEEN
FIFTEEN NINETEEN TWENTY THREE.
IN THE LAST SIX MONTHS TURKEY
AND AZERBAIJAN JOINED FORCES
AND ATTACKED THE REPUBLIC OF
ARTSAKH. OUR LARGER STANDING IS
THAT THOUSANDS WERE KILLED.
MORE THAN A COUPLE HUNDRED P.
O. W. STILL HAVE YET TO BE
RETURNED ARE THEIR WHEREABOUTS
ACCOUNTED FOR. AMERICA CANNOT
SIT IDLY BY. IN SELECTIVELY
CHOOSE WHICH MORAL HAZARD HAS
BEEN PERPETRATED AGAINST WHOM.
IF WE ARE A NATION OF LAWS IF
WE BELIEVE IN HUMAN RIGHTS AND
I BELIEVE WE ARE BOTH OF THOSE.
AT THE STATE. THEN WE NEED TO
MAKE CERTAIN. THAT WE INVOKE.
OUR PRIORITIES WITH RUSSIA WITH
FRANCE THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
MEN'S GROUP. HOLD TURKEY AND
AZERBAIJAN ACCOUNTABLE. THE
CAUCUSES VERY COMPLICATED AREA
OF THE WORLD. BUT WE CANNOT
COMMEMORATE- THIS GENOCIDE. IF
WE ARE TO FORSAKE WHAT IT MEANS
TO ACTIVATE AND PREVENT WANTS
TO COME. I WANT TO GIVE IT IN
APPS THAT'S THE EXTENT ABSOLUTE
GRATITUDE. THE PRESIDENT BIDEN.
I HAVE SEEN MORE REPUBLICANS
MORE DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT
CANADA PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES
SAY ONE THING AND DO THE EXACT
OFFICE DID THE EXACT OPPOSITE
UPON OF BECOMING PRESIDENT THIS
PRESIDENT ACTUALLY DID IT. NO
POLITICAL CIRCUMSTANCES NO
DOUBT OR A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT
NOW THAN THEY WERE IN THE PAST.
BUT POLITICAL CONVENIENCE IS
NEVER A PREDICATE. TO DOING THE
RIGHT THING. SO I SALUTE
PRESIDENT BIDEN I ALSO SALUTE-
CONGRESS FOR ITS PASSAGE OF
RECOGNITION A COUPLE YEARS AGO.
SR TWENTY NINE RECOGNIZES THE
IN MOURNS THE LOSS OF MILLIONS
OF SOULS MORE THAN A CENTURY
AGO. BUT THE CALLS UPON EACH OF
US TO BE MINDFUL OF HISTORY.
AND PASS ALONG THESE LESSONS TO
OUR CHILDREN. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR BORDERS FOR YOUR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF SR
TWENTY NINE WILL NOT GO TO
SENATOR PAN FOLLOWED BY CENTER
DRAWS SO SENATOR PAN YOU HAVE
THE FLOOR THANK YOU MR%
PRESIDENT SENATORS AS CHAIR OF
THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I AM HONORED
TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF SR TWENTY
NINE WHICH RECOGNIZES THE
HUNDRED SIXTY ANNIVERSARY OF
THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE. I WANT
TO THANK MY GOOD FRIEND FROM
PICO RIVERA FOR CALLING US
CALLING ON ALL OF US TO
COMMEMORATE THE HISTORY BEHIND
THE HORRENDOUS EVENTS THAT
OCCURRED DURING THE NINETEEN
FIFTEEN TO NINETEEN BETWEEN
NINETEEN FIFTY NINETEEN TWENTY
THREE THAT LED TO THE DEATHS OF
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION PEOPLE
OF ARMENIAN DESCENT. ON THIS
DAY WE REMEMBER THE VICTIMS
HOWEVER REMINDED THAT WE MUST
STAND TOGETHER AGAINST THE
DANGERS THAT AIM TO TARGET
PEOPLE BASED ON THEIR RACE
RELIGION POLITICAL VIEWS. AND
OUR CULTURES. DURING THESE
DIVISIVE TIMES WE NEED TO BE
MINDFUL OF HISTORY. AS WE
RECOGNIZE THIS MASSIVE
VIOLATION OF HUMAN RIGHTS AND
THE GENOCIDE OF THE ARMENIAN
PEOPLE. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR YOUR SUPPORT FOR SR TWENTY
NINE THANK YOU. THERE PAN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF SR TWENTY NINE WILL
NOW MOVE TO SENATOR ALSO
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR STERN
CENTER DRAWS SO YOU HAVE THE
FLOOR. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FROM A SENATOR FROM BIG WOULD
LEAVE IT AT AND THE SENATOR
FROM LEBANON OF FLINT RIDGE.
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON ON THIS
ISSUE. I RISE ALSO IN SUPPORT
OF SR TWENTY NINE. AS THE
NEWEST MEMBER OF THE ARMENIAN
CAUCUS NEVER PRESENT LITTLE
ARMENIA IN SENATE DISTRICT
TWENTY FOUR. I HONOR THE MEMORY
OF THE ONE AND A HALF MILLION
ARMENIANS WHO PERISHED. IN THE
HANDS OF THE OTTOMAN TURKS IN
NINETEEN FIFTEEN. ONE HUNDRED
AND FIVE YEARS AGO. I CAN'T
HELP TO THINK ABOUT ALL THOSE
SURVIVORS WE DIDN'T GET TO SEE
THIS DAY. THANK YOU PRESIDENT
BIDEN THANK YOU GOVERNOR
NEWSOM. FOR BRINGING SOME
COMFORT TO THE ARMENIAN
COMMUNITY. DECLARING THE LOSS
OF LIVES A GENOCIDE. S. AND P.
STORE LOST SISTERS AND BROTHERS
NOW LET US FOCUS ON THE PRESENT
MAKE SURE THAT ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE TREATED WITH
JUSTICE AND FAIRNESS. AND MAY
THEY BE GENOCIDE SURVIVORS OR
AN IMMIGRANT LOOKING FOR A HOME
FOR HIS OR HER FAMILY IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR RAZA FOR YOUR KIND
WORDS AND SUPPORT OF SR TWENTY
NINE WILL NOW MOVE ONLINE TO
CENTERS STERN CENTER STERN
WELCOME TO THE SESSION GOOD TO
SEE YOU. YOU HAVE NOTHING- I
RISE IS IT NOT ONLY EAT
PRIMARILY IN. CAUCUS OR A THE
SENATOR FROM LOCKING YADA
FLAYED REACHES SELECT
COMMITTEE- ON ARMENIA
CALIFORNIA ARMENIA ARTSAKH. A
RELATION BUT AS SOMEONE WHO HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY WITH THE
SENATOR FROM LOOKING AT IT FOR
YOU FLINTRIDGE TO PUT MY FEET
ON THE GROUND IN ARMENIA AND TO
SEE WHAT LIFE IS LIKE FOR A
GENERATION. THAT SURVIVE.
THERE'S A PHRASE. IN NORTHERN
AIM AT TO BE ARMENIAN IS AN
IMPOSSIBILITY. IT'S A DARK
HISTORY OF SURVIVAL AND TRIUMPH
AND I KNOW WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE COMMEMORATION OF THE
GENOCIDE TODAY NOT AS A PLEA TO
THE WHITE HOUSE OR TO THE
COUNTRY BUT AS AN AFFIRMATION
AND IT'S A REFRESHING MOMENT IN
THAT WAY. BUT I EIGHT I WOULD
BE REMISS- ALSO IS A MEMBER OF
THE JEWISH CAUCUS WITH. A
FAMILY THAT'S MADE IT. THROUGH
A THEIR OWN GENOCIDE. ARE THE
SIMILARITIES BETWEEN THE
HOLOCAUST IN THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE OR NOT JUST- ACADEMIC.
THE OTTOMAN TURKS TAUGHT THE
**** HOW TO CONDUCT MASS
SLAUGHTER SYSTEMATICALLY. BUT
THE FLIP SIDE IF THE RESILIENCE
OF THE ARMENIAN PEOPLE. AND THE
KIND OF RESISTANCE THAT WAS
PROVIDED AGAINST THIS
SLAUGHTER- WAS ALSO RESONATE
WITH THE JEWISH PEOPLE. IT IS A.
IT WAS WRITTEN ABOUT THE
ARMENIAN RESISTANCE TO THIS
GENOCIDE. AND COPIES OF THAT
BOOK PERMITTED THROUGH THE
GHETTOS OF EASTERN EUROPE. IN
THE **** CLOSED IN ON THE JEWS.
AS A FORM OF SOME KIND OF
INSPIRATION. AND IT DIDN'T SAVE
MANY BUT IT I KNOW THAT BECAUSE
THE SHARED RESILIENCE. IT'S NOT
JUST BETWEEN THE ARMENIAN
PEOPLE THE JEWISH PEOPLE OR ALL
OF THE PEOPLE OF LOS ANGELES OR
EVEN CALIFORNIA WHO SHARE THIS
MAKES CULTURAL HERITAGES IT'S
SOMETHING OUNDATIONAL TO THAT
DNA- AND WE'RE ALL GRATEFUL TO
REPRESENT THE ARMENIAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY IN THE DIASPORA HERE
ABOUT TO STAND HERE AND
COMMEMORATE COMMEMORATION TO
SAY NEVER AGAIN. AND TO COMMIT
OURSELVES TO THE WORK THAT'S
NEEDED TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN
THANK. THANK YOU CENTER STERN
FOR YOUR WORDS IN SUPPORT OF SR
TWENTY NINE SENATORS ARE THERE
ANY MORE. COMMENTS IN SUPPORT
OF SR TWENTY NINETY MORE
DISCUSSION ON SR TWENTY NINE
SENATOR WILK YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MR THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. I'VE GONE BACK AND
FORTH THE TERMS IS IN TERMS OF
SPEAKING BECAUSE SATURDAY WAS A
MONUMENTAL DAY FOR DUDLEY THE
ARMENIAN COMMUNITY BUT FOR ALL
PEOPLE ONE OF THE WORST DAYS OF
MY LIFE WAS SIX YEARS AGO. WHEN
I JOIN IN MANY YOU IN THIS ROOM
CHOI AND- OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND ARMENIANS THAT MARTIAN
IN OWNTOWN LOS ANGELES TO THE
TO THE TURKISH EMBASSY. ANYBODY
WHO KNOWS SOMEBODY. WHO'S
ARMENIAN WILL HEAR STORIES
ABOUT ABOUT. THE GENOCIDE AND
WHAT HAPPENED TO THEIR FAMILY
AND TO HAVE THAT INDIGNANTLY
DENIED. FOR GENERATIONS. IS
JUST AS BAD AND IT JUST IT JUST
JUST TEARS AT THEIR SOLVE
SATURDAY MORNING MY WIFE'S
GETTING YOUR HAIR DONE- UP-
WRITING THE SPEECH FOR THIS
FRIDAY M. I. A NINETY FOUR YEAR
OLD MOTHER LIVE WHO LIVES WITH
US IS A WAILING AND I RUN DOWN
THE STAIRS BECAUSE I THOUGHT
SOMETHING WAS WRONG BUT SHE
JUST GOT A NOTICE ON HER PHONE.
THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN. DECLARED
THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE JUST THAT
A GENOCIDE AND I WANT TO THANK
pTHAT IT CIRCUMSTANCES MADE IT
MAY CHANGE BUT I DON'T CARE IT
SHOULD BEEN DONE A LONG TIME
AGO AND HE HAS NOTHING BUT MY
RESPECT. RESPECT FOR THAT. HEY
ANY WAS NOT ONLY ARMENIANS AND
AS MENTIONED EARLIER IS THE
SYRIANS IT WAS IT WAS GREEKS
AND IF YOU GO TO THE AND I HOPE
I THINK THE SENATE'S GOING TO
GO TO ARMENIAN NEXT YEAR AND I
HOPE THAT THEY DO AND I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO GO AND WHEN
YOU GO IN YOU ARE IN THE
GENOCIDE MUSEUM. IN DOWNTOWN
YEREVAN. AND YOU WALK THROUGH
IT WHO'S THERE WITH THE OTTOMAN
TURKS. CARRYING OUT GENOCIDE
IT'S GERMAN SOLDIERS. HITLER
TICKETS PLAYBOOK FROM THE
OTTOMAN EMPIRE AND THE REASON
WHY WE NEED TO LEARN ALL THESE
THINGS THIS IS- THIS IS NEVER
REPLICATED AGAINST ANOTHER
PEOPLE GROUP. EVER AGAIN. SO
I'LL BE HALF OF MY WIFE BUT
THIS IS A FLAYED HER FAMILY
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR ALL THESE
YEARS ADVOCATING FOR THIS. AND
IT IN SATURDAY'S MON MONUMENTAL
DAY PRESHEAF THIS WE'RE NOT
DONE THERE ARE STILL A LOT OF
INJUSTICE IN THE WORLD IN
PARTICULAR IN THIS REGION. I
KNOW A LOT AMERICANS DON'T CARE
BECAUSE IT'S NOT. YOU KNOW A
STRATEGIC AREA FOR US BUT AS
MENTIONED EARLY EARLIER IT'S A
IT'S A IT'S A MORAL IMPERATIVE
FOR US SO I CAN I WANT TO THANK
YOU AND I THINK PRESIDENT
BIDEN. AND ENCOURAGE EVERYBODY
TO START FOR SR TWENTY NINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER
WILL PROPOSE VERY COMPASSION.
WORDS REGARDING SR TWENTY NINE.
SENATORS IS THERE ANY OTHER.
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE REGARDING SR TWENTY
NINE. SENATORS ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON SR
TWENTY NINE. SEEING NONE SENATE
ARCHULETA WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YES THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I'D LIKE TO THANK ALL
THE SENATORS WHO SPOKE TODAY
AND- IN RECOGNITION OF THIS
ANNIVERSARY THIS SATURDAY BUT%
GETS A HAPPY DAY THAT EVEN
WHERE ETHNOLOGY THE GENOCIDE.
BUT THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE. A
HUNDRED AND SIX ANNIVERSARY YES
I BELIEVE IT'S TOUCH ALL OF US
TO REALIZE THAT. THINGS LIKE
THIS HAPPEN IN OUR WORLD IT IS
HAPPEN T IS HISTORY AND WE
CANNOT ALLOW TO HAPPEN AGAIN.
IN FOR ALL OF US WHO HAVE
FRIENDS AND RELATIVES WHO HAVE
FRIENDS AND RELATIVES THAT ARE
ARMENIAN AMERICANS. THIS IS A
VERY SPECIAL DAY FOR US HERE IN
CALIFORNIA I'D LIKE TO THANK
OUR PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN OUR
GOVERNOR AND ALL OF YOU
SENATORS. WHO'VE BEEN TOUCHED
BY THE WORDS THAT WE'VE HEARD
TODAY IN WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY
ASK WOULD I VOTE ON SR TWENTY
NINE. THANK YOU CENTER
ARCHULETA- EXCELLENT JOB
LEADING US TO THIS DISCUSSION.
MURS THIS QUALIFIES FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ARE THERE
ANY OBJECTIONS TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NONE THE ITEM
PASSES THIRTY EIGHT AYE VOTES
ZERO NO VOTES CONGRATULATIONS
MISTER ARCHULETA AND THANK YOU
MR PORTANTINO FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AS
WELL. MEMBERS WE GONNA START
WORKING THROUGH THE DAILY FILE
ON SENATE THIRD READING FOR AS
LONG AS WE CAN THIS MORNING SO
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER SIXTEEN. S. C. R.
EIGHTEEN BY SENATOR CORTESE AND
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON THROUGH THE
FILE AFTER THAT AS MUCH AS WE
CAN GET DONE TODAY BUT WE'LL
RECOGNIZE CENTER CORTESE ON
FILE ITEM SIXTEEN S. C. R.
EIGHTEEN. CENTER COURT.
SECRETARY PLEASE REACH. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION EIGHTEEN
BY SENATOR CORTEZ C. RELATIVE
TO COMPASSIONATE CALIFORNIA.
THE COURTESY OF THE FLOOR. SO
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT TODAY
ARISE TO PRESENT S. C. R.
EIGHTEEN WHICH WOULD PROCLAIM
CALIFORNIA TO BE A
COMPASSIONATE STATE THE CHARTER
FOR COMPASSION WAS UNVEILED AT
THE UNITED NATIONS IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE. WE'RE CARRIED
FORTH A VISION OF CREATING A
GLOBAL CIVIL SOCIETY THAT WOULD
ASK US TO TREAT OTHERS AS WE
WOULD LIKE TO BE TREATED WITH
EMPIRICAL EVIDENCE THAT
SHOWCASES PRACTICING COMPASSION
CAN PRODUCE POSITIVE BENEFITS
IN VARIOUS SECTORS OF CIVIC AND
COMMUNITY LIFE. OUR STATE IS
HOME TO MANY INDUSTRIES
ORGANIZATIONS AND INDIVIDUALS
WHO SEEK TO SERVE THE NEEDS OF
OUR OF OUR COMMUNITIES THROUGH
COMPASSION. AND IT'S THROUGH
THEM THAT WE'VE RISEN TO BE A
MODEL OF COMPASSION WITHIN OUR
OWN UNION. WELL S. C. R.
EIGHTEEN IS NOT AN OFFICIAL
ADOPTION OF THE NATIONAL
CHARTER OF COMPASSION. IT DOES
EXPRESS THIS AUGUST BODIES
INTENT TO BE A LEADING EXAMPLE
FOR COMPASSION ACROSS THE GLOBE
IT'S FOR THESE REASONS AND MANY
MORE. THE URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
S. C. R. EIGHTEEN THANK YOU.
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON S. C. R. EIGHTEEN.
MEMBERS JUST REQUIRES A ROLL
CALL VOTE AND BEFORE WE GO TO
THAT ONE MORE CALL ON- DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION. SING NINE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES. BAKER FIVE FORGES.
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO HI
CORTESE I DALLY. DODD FIVE TO
RAZA I EGGMAN I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG
ALL RIGHT HI WITH SO. FIVE HER
TADO I JONES. KAMLAGER I
LAYERED I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE HI
MELENDEZ. MAN HI NEWMAN.
NIELSEN I CHOI BOGUE. PAN I
PORTANTINO I ROTH HI RUBIO I
SKINNER. HI I'M BURKE I AM I
RIGHT CASTING. I WIENER AYE
WILK. MEMBERS RUN GO THROUGH
THE ROLE ONE MORE TIME
SECRETARY IF YOU CAN PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES
PORGES. DALLY GROVE. JONES
MELENDEZ. NEWMAN AYE A CHILL OF
BOTH I WILK. I. MEMBERS FILE
ITEM SIXTEEN STR EIGHTEEN
PASSES THIRTY TWO EYES ZERO
KNOWS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM NINETEEN SENATOR
RUBIO. WITH US SENATE BILL TWO
SIXTY THREE CENTER CENTER RUBY
ARE YOU READY TO PRESENT. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT SECRETARY WILL
READ. SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY
THREE BY SENATOR RUBIO AND
AFTER LEADING TO REAL ESTATE.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO YOU
HAVE THE FLOOR. THANK YOU
MEDICARE- AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE TODAY
TO PRESENT SB TWO SIXTY THREE
AN IMPORTANT BILL THAT WILL
HELP CORRECT A LONG HISTORY OF
BIAS AGAINST PEOPLE OF COLOR
WHEN IT COMES TO HOME
OWNERSHIP. SB TWO SIXTY THREE
REQUIRES REAL ESTATE
PROFESSIONALS TO TAKE IMPLICIT
BIAS TRAINING AS PART OF THEIR
CONTINUING EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS WE CAN AND MUST DO
BETTER IN THIS AREA. THAT IS
COSTING HOME OWNERSHIP GAP TO
CONTINUE TO GROW AMONG PEOPLE
OF COLOR AND THE MOST AFFLUENT.
REAL ESTATE PROFESSIONALS KNOW
THAT AS WELL THAT IS WHY
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS HAVE SPONSORED THIS
BILL. EIGHT TWENTY TWENTY
REPORT BY THE GREENLIGHTING
INSTITUTE FOUND THAT
CALIFORNIANS BLACK OWNERSHIP
RATE IS 35% AND CALIFORNIA'S
LATINO HOMEOWNERSHIP RATE IS
42% BOTH OF THESE RATES ARE FAR
LOWER THAN CALIFORNIA'S OVERALL
HOMEOWNERSHIP RATE. MEMBERS
THERE IS A CONSENSUS ON THIS
ISSUE. AND THIS BILL RECEIVED
OVERWHELMING BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
IN COMMITTEES AND THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION ON FILE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON SB TWO SIXTY THREE
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON TWO
SIXTY THREE. CENTER ARCHULETA
YOUR RECOGNIZE I THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT ELECTED KNOWLEDGE THE
AUTHOR IS A VERY VERY IMPORTANT
BILL AS YOU KNOW I'M THERE-
LICENSED REAL ESTATE BROKER
THAT'S BEEN MY TRADE IN TO HAVE
A BILL LIKE THIS TOUCH ALL REAL
ESTATE AGENTS ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA TO RECOGNIZE
IMPLICIT BIAS. THIS IS A
TERRIBLE TERRIBLE THING AND IF
WE'RE GOING TO OPEN THE DOORS
O QUALITY TO HOMEOWNERSHIP
WE'VE GOT TO TRAIN THOSE WHO
ARE LICENSED TO UNDERSTAND THAT
BIGOTRY IS OUT THERE PREJUDICE
IS OUT THERE IN IT SHOULD NEVER
BE INVOLVED IN THE PROFESSION
OF REAL ESTATE AND WE WANT TO
OPEN THOSE DOORS TO EVERYONE
ACROSS THE BOARD TO BE ABLE TO
OBTAIN THAT DREAM OF
HOMEOWNERSHIP AND I THANK THE
AUTHOR ONCE AGAIN. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SAID
ARCHULETA ANY OTHER MEMBERS ANY
OTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
SB TWO SIXTY THREE. ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SENATOR
RUBIO WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
YES THANK A LOT LIKE TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUE FROM PICO RIVERA
FOR HIS COMMENTS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASTRONOMICAL THANK
YOU THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO
MEMBERS JUST REQUIRES A ROLL
CALL VOTE SECRETARY PLEASE
READ- PLEASE- CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES I BAKER I BORJAS AYE
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO HIGH
COURT HAS HE- I DALLY I DODD I
TO RAZA. I EGGMAN I GLAZER FIVE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH I HERTZBERG
AYE HUESO. I FURTADO AYE JONES.
KAMLAGER I LAYERED I LEYVA I
MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S AYE MIN.
FIVE NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN I A
TOWBOAT I PAN AYE PORTANTINO I
ROTH HI RUBIO. HI SKINNER. HI
I'M BURKE HI WE CASTING AYE
WIENER AYE WILK HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBER. JONES HI HI.
THANK YOU MEMBERS FILE ITEM
NINETEEN S. C. R. I. S. B. TWO
SIXTY THREE PASSES- THIRTY
EIGHT EYES ZERO KNOWS WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON A FILE ITEM
TWENTY ONE. SENATE BILL THREE
EIGHTY SIX SENATOR UMBERG. IF
YOU'RE READY. THE SECRETARY
WILL READ SENATE BILL THREE
EIGHTY SIX BY SENATOR UMBERG
AND AFTER LEADING TO ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES CENTER O'BYRNE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS- I
MONITOR PRESENT SB THREE EIGHTY
SIX A BILL THAT WOULD EXPAND
EXISTING SPONSORSHIP TIED HOUSE
EXEMPTION TO ALLOW THE OWNERS
OF THE HONDA CENTER IN ORANGE
COUNTY TO ACCESS- TO HAVE THE
ACCESS PRIVILEGES SELL
ADVERTISING ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES. THROUGHOUT THE
NINETY FIVE ACRE MASTER PLANNED
DEVELOPMENT WHICH WILL INCLUDE
THE HONDA CENTER WHERE WHERE-
IS YOU ARE THE TOURISM
ENTERTAINMENT HOSPITALITY
INDUSTRY ARE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TAKEN VERY HARD HIT
TO THE PUBLIC NINE PAN NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. BOB SB THREE EIGHTY
SIX WILL HELP MY DISTRICT IN
THE REGION RECOVER FROM THE
PANDEMIC BY SPORTING AND NEW
DEVELOPMENT OPPORTUNITIES
COUNTY WHICH WILL PLAY A
CRITICAL ROLE CREATING JOBS
REVITALIZING THE LOCAL ECONOMY.
POST CODE NINETEEN THE PROJECT-
C. FIVE WILL CREATE ABOUT TEN
THOUSAND CONSTRUCTION JOBS AND
THREE THOUSAND PERMANENT JOBS.
OF OUR SPONSORS IN MY OFFICE
MENTAL REACH AGREEMENT WITH
RESPECT TO ANY OUTDOOR
ADVERTISING ISSUES AND I URGE
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER AMBERG MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON SB
THREE EIGHTY SIX SENATOR MEN.
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I ALSO RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS PARTICULAR-
EXEMPTION TO THE TIED HOUSE
RULES- THIS WILL AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA ANA
MENTIONED. BE A MAJOR SOURCE OF
JOBS IT'S GOING TO BE AN
ECONOMIC POWERHOUSE FOR OUR
REGION AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR FOR YOUR IPHONE. THANK
YOU CENTER MEN ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON. THREE
EIGHTY SIX. ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON SB
THREE EIGHTY SIX SEEING NONE
CENTER- BURKE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU MISS PRESENT
NUMBERS LETTERS NOVEL THANK YOU
SERRA BURKE MEMBERS THIS
QUALIFIES FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION. TO
USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL WE
HAVE ONE OBJECTION MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES I BAKER. I FOR JUST I
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO HI
CORTESE HI DALLY. I DODD I TO
RAZA I EGGMAN I GLAZER NO
GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH. HERTZBERG
AYE HUESO. I HER TADO HI JONES
I KAMLAGER I LAYERED I LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S AYE MAN.
I NEWMAN I NIELSEN I A
CHILLAGOE I PAN I PORTANTINO. I
ROTH I RUBIO FIVE SKINNER. FIVE
NUMBER I WHITE HOUSE E. FIVE
WIENER AYE WILK HI MINIM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GROVE HI. THAT
MEASURE PASSES THIRTY SEVEN TO
ONE SB THREE EIGHTY SIX PASSES
THANK YOU CENTER AMBERG MOVING
ONTO FILE ITEM TWENTY FIVE S.
R. TWENTY ONE CENTER PAN-
SECRETARY WILL READ. SENATE
RESOLUTION TWENTY ONE BY
SENATOR PAN RELATIVE TO MISKITO
AWARENESS WEEKS CENTER PAN
LOOKS LIKE HE'S READY PRESENTS
THEIR VALUE HAVE THE FLOOR
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT SENATORS
TODAY I'M PRESENTING SR TWENTY
ONE RESOLUTION TO RECOGNIZE
MISKITO VECTOR CONTROL
AWARENESS WEEK. WHICH WAS LAST
WEEK ACTUALLY FROM APRIL
EIGHTEENTH APRIL TWENTY FOURTH.
AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE MOSQUITO
BORNE DISEASES CONTINUE TO BE
AMONG THE WORLD'S LEADING
CAUSES OF ILLNESS AND DEATH AND
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE SEEN
THE SPREAD OF INVASIVE DISEASES
THAT TRANSMIT. INVASIVE SPECIES
THAT TRANSMIT SERIOUS DISEASES
LIKE SECA. WITH RISING COVERED
VACCINATION RATES WERE
CERTAINLY ALL ANXIOUS TO SAFELY
SPEND TIME OUTDOORS AND START
EXPLORING HOWEVER THE
MOSQUITOES THE SO OUT THERE
INVESTIGATORS CAN CARRY SERIOUS
DISEASES LIKE WEST NILE VIRUS
WHICH IN FACT ALMOST TWO
HUNDRED PEOPLE THROUGHOUT
TWENTY FOUR COUNTIES LAST YEAR.
BUT WE CAN KEEP OURSELVES.
ENTERTAINED BUT SAFE BY WEARING
BOTH EPA REGISTERED INSECT
REPELLENT AND REMOVING ALL
STAGNANT WATER AROUND YOUR
HOUSE SO DOES IT STILL RAIN
EVEN DURING THE DROUGHT- IN
ADDITION TO THESE INDIVIDUAL
EFFORTS WELL FUNDED MOSQUITO
VECTOR CONTROL DISEASE
SURVEILLANCE OF PUBLIC
AWARENESS PROGRAMS COUPLED WITH
BEST MANAGEMENT PRACTIES AND
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE LANDS ARE
THE BEST WAY TO PREVENT
OUTBREAKS OF MOSQUITO BORNE
DISEASES. AND TWENTY NINETEEN
THE WITH THIS LEGISLATURE
ESTABLISHED THE CALIFORNIANS
GET A SURVEILLANCE RESEARCH
PROGRAM SUPPORT ADVANCED DATA
COLLECTION AND ANALYSIS TOOLS
WHICH WILL HELP US COMBAT THE
SPREAD OF MOSQUITO BORNE
ILLNESSES. PLEASE HELP US FIGHT
THE BITE I REGION AYE VOTE
RECOGNIZE MISKITO VECTOR
CONTROL AWARENESS WEEK THANK
YOU. CENTER PAN THANK YOU ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. ON S. R.
TWENTY ONE. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. CENTER NIELSEN YOUR
RECOGNIZE. MISTER PRESIDENT
GLAZER ON THE SENATE LET ME
JOIN IN AS ONE WHO GREW UP IN
AN AREA THAT WAS PLAGUED WITH
THE SCHOOL. BUT I WANT TO GIVE
A- SHOUT OUT FOR THE MEN AND
WOMEN IN THE SCHEDULE ABATEMENT
CONTROL DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. WHO LABOR
THROUGHOUT THE SEASON. THE
CONTAINER THE MOSQUITOES HERE
IN CALIFORNIA THE BEST THAT
THEY CAN'T. THERE ARE A
NUISANCE BUT AS THE GOOD DOCTOR
HAS MENTIONED THAT THEY ARE
ALSO A DISASTER WITH MAJOR
CONSEQUENCES TO US. I JUST
WOULD LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE. YOU
ABATEMENT DISTRICT EMPLOYEES
WHO PROBABLY NEVER EVER GET
MENTIONED BUT THEY CERTAINLY
ARE AT THE VANGUARD OF GIVING
US RELIEF FROM THIS TERRIBLE
PASSED. THANK YOU CENTER NELSON
ANY OTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
FROM THE MEMBERS. SENATOR PAN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I WOULD
LIKE TO FIRST OF ALL THANK MY
GOOD FRIEND THE HAM OFFERS-
WISE AND- POURTANT WORDS ON
THIS ISSUE ARE STRICTLY OUT
TONIHT BUT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR PAN MEMBERS THIS
QUALIFIES FOR UNANIMOUS CONSENT
DOES ANYBODY OBJECT TO
UNANIMOUS CONSENT AND FIGHTING
THE FIGHT. I'M SORRY UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL I'M TRYING TO BE
FUNNY AND I MESSED IT UP-
MEMBERS THIS QUALIFIES FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL NO
OBJECTION- THIS MEASURE PASSES
THIRTY EIGHT. ZERO FILE ITEM
TWENTY FIVE SR TWENTY ONE
PASSES THIRTY EIGHT TWO ZERO
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO. FILE ITEM TWENTY SEVEN. S.
J. R. ONE. BY SENATOR ALAN. AND
THE SECRETARY WILL READ. SENATE
JOINT RESOLUTION ONE BY SENATOR
ALAN RELATIVE TO STUDENT LOAN
DEBT. CINDERELLA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED GOOD AFTERNOON MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS OF THIS
RESOLUTION SJR ONE CALLS ON
PRESIDENT BIDEN TO. FORGET A
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL STUDENT LOAN DEBT FOR
STUDENT BORROWERS ACROSS THE
NATION THIS IS A THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES RECOMMENDATION
WE ALL KNOW OF COURSE THE HOUSE
BECAUSE OF HIGHER EDUCATION IS
RISING. ASSEMBLY TEASLEY
STUDENT LOAN DEBT IN OUR STATE
ACROSS THE NATION IS
SKYROCKETED INCREASING A 100%
OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS I JUST
DON'T THINK THAT- THAT DOES
THOSE OF US- MEMBERS WHO WENT
TO. TIRED WE'VE GOT I GOT A
COLLEGE EDUCATIONS- AWHILE BACK
EVEN CAN CAN FATHOM HOW MUCH
WE'RE ASKING THE YOUNG PEOPLE
TO LEVERAGE OUR FUTURE SOLICIT
SIMPLY AFFORD TO- HIGHER
EDUCATION. BY TWENTY TWENTY
OVER FIFTY NEARLY FIFTY MILLION
PEOPLE LOAD MORE THAN ONE POINT
SEVEN TRILLION DOLLARS IN
STUDENT LOAN DEBT IN
CALIFORNIA. IT'S OVER THREE
MILLION BORROWERS WHO OWE A
HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN MILLION AN
AVERAGE OF NEARLY FORTY
THOUSAND PER BORROWER. AND THIS
REALLY IMPACTS BUT SO MUCH OF
OUR OF OUR WAY OF LIFE IT IT
BURNS ECONOMY IN WAYS THAT I
DON'T KNOW THAT FOLKS FULLY
GRAPPLE WITH THE MINUTE DELAYS
THE ABILITY OF MILLIONS TO BUY
HOMES. TO REACH FINANCIAL
MILESTONES TO HAVE THE
CONFIDENCE TO START A NEW
BUSINESS HI EVEN EVEN HAVE THE
CONFIDENCE TO HAVE A CHILD-
GIVEN HOW EXPENSIVE IT IS. TO
RAISE IT TO RAISE A KID I THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS
STUDENTS WHOSE FAMILIES CANNOT
HELP THEM PAY FOR THEIR
EDUCATION. WHICH WHICH OF
COURSE FURTHER EXACERBATES- THE
MANY- ANY QUALITIES THAT EXISTS
FOR LOWER INCOME AND FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS AND SO. ON
THIS. PUTS US ON RECORD AS
SUPPORTING. HI THIS FIFTY THE
DOLLAR. LOAN CANCELLATION. I
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAY
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER ALLEN
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS J. R. ONE.
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE IF THE
SECRETARY CAN PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS I BATES. BAKER. HI
BURGESS BRADFORD. CABALLERO I
CORTES E. HI DALLY. DODD I
TORONTO HI EGGMAN. GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROWTH HERTZBERG I
WISH SO. HI HER TADO. JONES NO
KAMLAGER I LAYERED AYE LEYVA I
MCGUIRE. HI MELINDA'S. MAN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. BUT CHAU A
VOGUE. PAN FIVE PORTANTINO. I
ROTH I RUBIO HI SKINNER HI I'M
BURKE RIGHT I BY CASTING AYE
WIENER AYE WILK NOW. MEMBERS
WILL GO THROUGH THE ROLE ONE
MORE TIME IF THE SECRETARY CAN
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
FAITH FOR JUST. BRADFORD HI
DOLLY NO EGGMAN. I GROWTH NO
HER TADO I MELENDEZ NO. NIELSEN.
BUT CHAU A BUG. NO. THANK YOU
MEMBERS OF FARM TWENTY SEVEN AS
J. R. ONE IS IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED THIRTY AYE VOTES
FIVE NO VOTES- WE WILL MOVE ON
TO FILE ITEM TWENTY EIGHT.
SENATOR DODD S. B. TO NINETY
EIGHT. SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL TWO NINETY EIGHT BY
SENATOR DODD AN ACT RELATING TO
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES. CENTER
DODD YOU HAVE THE FLOOR. MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS SB TWO NINE
EIGHT ALLOWS THE OWNER OF A
BREW PUB RESTAURANT LICENSE
ALSO KNOWN AS TYPE SEVENTY FIVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO EXCHANGE
THAT LICENSE FOR AN ALCOHOL
REST RESTAURANT LICENSE OR TYPE
FORTY SEVEN LICENSE. THIS BILL
WOULD ALLOW LICENSEES THE
ABILITY TO EXCHANGE OUR LICENSE
FOR ALCOHOL RESTAURANT LICENSE
THIS MIRRORS- CHANGE- A
PROVISION IN STATE LAW WHICH
ALLOWS LICENSE EVEN ALCOHOL
RESTAURANT LICENSE TO EXCHANGE
OUR LICENSE FOR A BAR LICENSE
AND VICE VERSA RESPECTFULLY ASK
DR THE- THANK YOU SENATOR DODD
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON SB TO
NINETY EIGHT. THIS QUALIFIES
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL THE
MEASURE PASSES THIRTY EIGHT
ZERO CONGRADULATIONS MISTER
DODD SENATOR DODD WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM THIRTY. WE
HAVE A SENATOR DODD AGAIN ON SB
ONE THREE IF THE SECRETARY CAN
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL ONE OH
THREE BY SENATOR DODD AND
ACTUALLY DO TO ELECTIONS.
TENDER SHOT MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS WHAT AMERICAN VOTERS
CAST THEIR BALLOTS FOR
PRESIDENT UNITED STATES HERE
ELECTING  SLATE OF ELECTORS.
THESE ELECTORS THEN CAST
BALLOTS TO DECIDE WHO WILL BE
PRESIDENT IF THE STATE BALLOTS
ARE OUR CASTLE WHAT WAY THAT
REFLECTS THE WILL OF THE VOTERS
OUR DEMOCRACY CEASES TO VOTE TO
FUNCTION WITH THIS BILL
CALIFORNIA WILL JOIN THIRTY
OTHER STATES. THAT HAVE TAKEN
THE ACTION TO DISCOURAGE OR
FORBID FAITHLESS ELECTORAL
VOTES THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION RECEIVED NO NO VOTES
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR THE- CENTER
DOT THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON SB ONE ALL THREE MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. THIS ALSO
QUALIFIES FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
NATOMAS ROLL CALL. SEEING NONE
OF THE MEASURE PASSES THIRTY
EIGHT ZERO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO.
SENATOR DODD. YOU HAVE THE
RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO BE LOOKING
AT S. B. FOUR SEVENTEEN IF THE
SECRETARY CAN PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL FOUR SEVENTEEN BY
SENATOR DODD AN ACT RELATING TO
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES CENTER DOT
YOU CAN JUST STAY STANDING UP I
THINK WE HAVE SIX MORE ITEMS BY
YOU TODAY BUT YOU BOUGHT THIS
ONE THERE DODD YOU MAY OPEN
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
SP FOUR SEVENTEEN ALLOWS YOUR
COMMON CARRIERS THE ABILITY TO
TRACK AN ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES
INTO THE STATE FOR THE SOLE
PURPOSE OF SERVING THAT ALCOHOL
ON THEIR AIRPLANES WITHOUT THE
NEED TO OBTAIN IT IMPORTERS
LICENSE I'VE- THANKFULLY AFTER
I'VE A- MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON SB FOUR SEVENTEEN.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON SB FOUR
SEVENTEEN. SEEING NONE THIS
ALSO QUALIFIES FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL CENTER DODD GOOD JOB
DOING THE PEOPLE'S BUSINESS
TODAY- THIS MAJOR IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL ON AS BEFORE SEVENTEEN.
SIX FOUR SEVENTEEN I'M SORRY SB
FOUR SEVENTEEN. SAYING NO
OBJECTION THE MEASURE PASSES
THIRTY EIGHT TO ZERO- MEMBERS
THIS IS THE LAST THIRD ITEM. I
THAT THURSDAY FILE ITEM WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. I DID NOT SERVE
OUR THIRTY EIGHT ZERO FOR MR
DOT. SO WE CAN GO ON TO MEMBERS
REMOVE ON THE COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS WE HAVE CENTER
HUESO IN CENTER CORTESE THAT
HAVE ANNOUNCEMENTS. SENATOR
CORTESE I SEE YOU FIRST AT YOUR
DESK. IF YOU CAN ANNOUNCE YOUR
COMMUNITIES. THE TICKET WAS
RESIDENT DELIVER PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT
COMMITTEE WILL MEET IN FOR TWO
OH THREE- UPON ADJOURNMENT OF
THE SESSION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER CORTESE CENTER HUESO
IN THE BACK THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT ENERGY
TELECOMMUNICATIONS UTILITIES-
COMMITTEE WILL MEET. HERE ON
THE SENATE FLOOR FROM THE
GERMAN I EXPECT IT'LL BE
EXACTLY AT THREE THIRTY IF WE
CAN HAVE MEMBERS. REPORT TO THE
FLOOR AT THREE THIRTY WILL TO
FOR US TO BREAK WE GET PROBLEMS
PROMPTLY. THANK YOU SENATOR
HUESO WITH HUESO WE'RE GOING TO
RETURN TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS MEMBERS WE HAVE
THREE ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
IF THERE IS NO OTHER MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS WILL MOVE ON TO
SENATOR RUBIO FOR HER
ADJOURNMENT MEMORY SENATOR
RUBIO. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
YES LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
THERMAL CARE ACT RISE WITH DEEP
SADNESS TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
HENRY JOSEPH THE LAWFUL FROM EL
MONTE THE MAN WHO ENJOY
PEOPLE'S COMPANY AND WAS FILLED
WITH HELPING OTHERS HENRY
SERVED HIS COUNTRY HONORABLY BY
INVESTING IN THE UNITED STATES
NAVY DURING THE KOREAN WAR
CONFLICT HE ORKED IN RADIO AND
TELEVISION FOR THE MAJORITY OF
HIS LIFE BECOMING A SOUND
ENGINEER FOR KF FIVE
BROADCASTING AND LATER LOW MEN
AND BERKELEY ENGINEER. HENRY
WAS DEDICATED TO UPLIFTING THE
CITY OF A MONEY SERVICE COUNCIL
MEMBER FOR TEN AND A HALF YEARS
AND CITY TREASURER FOR TWENTY
THREE YEARS BEFORE HE RETIRED
AT AGE EIGHTEEN I HAD THE HONOR
AND PRIVILEGE OF WORKING WITH
HIM GETTING TO KNOW HIM AND
SPENDING TIME AND HE WAS JUST
SUCH AN HONORABLE MAN HENRY HAD
A TO PASSION FOR VOLUNTEERING
HE WAS AN ACTIVE PARISHIONER
AND HIS CHURCH AS WELL AS A
MEMBER OF THE MOOSE
INTERNATIONAL AMERICAN LEGION
THE ALMONTY ENDS THE VFW AND
THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE HE LEFT
TO GET BACK AND RECEIVED MANY
NOTABLE. ACCOLADES INCLUDING
THE UNITED STATES NAVY LEGAL
WAR AND THE PRESIDENTIAL AGENT
OF MERIT HONOR ROLL HIS MARK IN
LEGACY IN THE COMMUNITY WILL
SERVE FOR GENERATIONS TO COME
AS HE DONATED HIS TIME AND
SERVICE POLICIES TO HELP OTHERS
HENRY IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
TERESA HIS CHILDREN CHRISTY TO
RE SIGN HENRY JERRY JOSEPH AND
ROBERT ALONG WITH ELEVEN
GRANDCHILDREN AND SEVEN GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN. HENRY LEFT A
LONG LASTING IMPACT ON THE
LIVES OF SO MANY AND WILL
SURELY BE MASS TO MY FRIENDS
IBM WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO I UNDERSTAND YOU
HAVE ONE MORE ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY AND THEN YOU WILL BE
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR. ON BURKE
CENTER RUBIO. SACRAMENTO YEAH
BY. AND SEVEN HAS TO IN THE
MEMORY OF RATE AND THE CITY OF
HUESCA. I'M SORRY CITY OF
COPING. MRS REYES AND FOR AND-
NORTH. AND ATTENDED THE
UNIVERSITY OF TEXAS WHERE SHE
MET THE LOVE OF HER LIFE.
ROBERT LEWIS COLLINS AFTER
GRADUATING IN NINETEEN FORTY
SEVEN RAY MOVED TO CALIFORNIA
AND MARRIED ROBERT IN MAY
NINETEEN FORTY NINE. TOGETHER
RAY AND HER HUSBAND ENJOYED
SEVENTY WONDERFUL YEARS
TOGETHER RAISING THEIR THREE
CHILDREN LINDA RICHARD AND
JULIE. AS AN ACCOMPLISHED FULL
LABORATORY TECH TECHNICIAN
REYES CAREER SPANNED SEVERAL
DECADES HE WAS INVOLVED IN MANY
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MEDICAL. TECHNOLOGIST DAUGHTER
OF THE AMERICAN REVOLUTION
CAMINO WOMAN'S CLUB GENEALOGY
CLUB REASONS TO BELIEVE IN HER
ARISH FIRST CHURCH HE
CONSISTENTLY MODEL COMPASSION.
AND FORGIVENESS MRS RECALL THIS
IS SURVIVED BY HER DAUGHTER
LINDA AND JULIE'S SON RICHARD
AND GRANDDAUGHTER CALLIE SHE
ALSO LEAVES BEHIND HER. KNEES
BARBARA AND NEPHEWS ROBERT.
ROLES NOW FOR YOUR WITH HAS AND
IT PEACE SHE LEAVES A LAST
LEGACY AMONG HOW OF LIFE'S AND
HER AND PACOCHA BE MET. THANK
YOU MISTER. THANK YOU RUBIO'S
UMBERG YOUR RECOGNIZE THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS- IT'S
WITH GREAT SADNESS THAT I RISE
TO HONOR THE LIFE AND- A PUBLIC
SERVICE OF ARTHUR'S SON.
BILLABLE SALT THE SALT ON HIM
ARE THERE WAS A LONG TIME
RESIDENT CITY COMMISSION PUBLIC
SERVICE. SERVANT IN SANTA ANA
DURING HIS TIME AT CNTRAL HIGH
SCHOOL ARE THE WAS EXTREMELY
INVOLVED IN CAMPUS ACTIVITIES
INCLUDING MODEL UNITED NATIONS.
HE WOULD GO ON TO RECEIVE A
DEGREE IN INTERNATIONAL
RELATIONS FROM THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA SAN DIEGO UPON
GRADUATING. HE BEGAN SERVING
OUR COMMUNITY BY SECURING AN
INTERNSHIP WITH THEN STATE
SENATOR LOU CORREA WE QUICKLY
MOVED UP THE RANKS AND BECAME A
DISTRICT FIELD REPRESENTATIVE.
AS A TOP DISTRICT
REPRESENTATIVE FOR MORE THAN
SIX YEARS ARTHUR WORKED
TIRELESSLY TO SUPPORT REPRESENT
THE SANTA ANA COMMUNITY.
DEDICATED HUNDREDS OF HOURS
HELPING CONSTITUENTS NAVIGATE
MAX OF STATE GOVERNMENT
RESOLVED ISSUES IDENTIFIED
RESOURCES FOR SMALL BUSINESSES
SENIOR STUDENTS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS SCHOOLS. VETERANS
PARENTS AND KDS WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS. ARTHUR RELISHED
SUPPORTING OUR COMMUNITY AND
JOINING IN CELEBRATIONS HE WAS
IT NEARLY EVERY SINGLE PARADE
IN SANTA ANA AND WAS VERY
ACTIVE IN. EVERY MAJOR HOLIDAY-
CREATING ELABORATE HAND CUT
SNOWFLAKES FIGURES CALLS FOR
THE- DE LAS MARCAS BAMBOO TREE
ARRANGEMENTS IT SEPTA. IS
DEEPLY MISSED AND HE WILL BE
MISSED- FOREVER BY HIS HUSBAND
JACOB HIS MOTHER PATRICIA HIS
FATHER IS SMILE HIS TWIN
BROTHER. JONATHAN AND HIS
LITTLE SISTER CRYSTAL. THANK
YOU IN S. JOIN ME AND- HIS LIFE
AND ADJOURNING HIS MEMORY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SERRA BURKE OF
THE SENATORS WILL PLEASE BRING
THEIR NAMES FORWARD FOR PROPER
RECOGNITION IN THE DAILY
JOURNAL. I THINK THAT WRAPS IT
UP FOR US TODAY SENATOR ATKINS
THERE IF THERE'S NO OTHER
BUSINESS THE DESK IS CLEAR.
MISTER PRESIDENT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH JOB WELL DONE TODAY GREAT
CONGRATULATIONS AND THANK YOU-
FOR FIVE PRESIDING OVER THIS
HEARING TODAY SESSION. THE NEXT
FULLER SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
THURSDAY APRIL TWENTY NINTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT NINE AM
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
CENTER ATKINS MEMBERS THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
I GUESS. THREE THIRTY PM AT
WHICH TIME THE GERMAN MOTION
WILL BE MADE AND WE WILL
RECONVENE THURSDAY AT NINE AM
THANK YOU MEMBERS.